to start with I'm going to talk about
why these things that we call mobile
phones aren't really mobile I've got one
in my pocket right now they are
definitely mobile so what do you mean so
if you look at the design of most mobile
phones most smartphone applications it's
all designed so for when you use them
you kind of look down at them you tap
away with your fingers every time you
actually interact with this device
you're supposed to stop have a look at
it and you touch the screen so it's kind
of I guess I call this stop to interact
there are some good apps out there now
if you strauber and RunKeeper and some
of these apps they're developed for
people who were running around or on
bite rides and they seem to be pretty
good I mean you go for a run with one
keeper in it tells you what your pace is
you know how fast you go and all this
sort of stuff you can get them to give
you directions and all sorts yes so yeah
there are good examples of these apps so
very good examples of design for it
particularly when you're looking at
designing for very specific situations
or when you're looking for designing for
situations aren't too extreme if you
look at a lot of these apps so if you
look at RunKeeper for example almost all
the interaction is done when you stopped
things really break down once people
start actually wanting to interact back
with a system in any way other than
running a little bit faster or slower I
do a lot of sports I'd say there's a
real benefit to doing physical activity
to doing exercise to running around to
moving to cycling what I'm arguing for
here is the design of what I call
interaction in motion so how can you
design systems which and let which are
usable while you are performing some
kind of kind of locomotion so why you
were why you were cycling while you're
driving while you're running while
you're even while you're swimming while
you're skydiving just anything really
you've always got two things happening
here is a person and they're moving in
some way I'll call that the locomotion
so they're doing some kind of movement
they're running they're cycling or
whatever but at the same time they're
doing some kind of interact
of activity with a piece of technology
on this diagram we have two axes the
inhibition so how much does your
movement inhibit the ability to interact
so if you're walking that would be kind
of somewhere down here it wouldn't be
very much below so walking would be kind
of somewhere down here as you went up so
if you started running it's much harder
actually to interact with devices if you
run then if you look at more extreme
things if you're say if you were rock
climbing it could be really hard it's a
kind of most difficult thing that I can
think of to build systems for is
swimming if you're trying to interact
with a device while you're swimming
pretty much everything is stopped
everything is blocked your legs are
always behind you your body is always
flat a lot of the time you have to
actually kind of move your arms in
particular patterns so your your arms
have to be in particular places so you
can't use those very much
you really can only see a tiny bit of
space just in front of your eyes you
can't use speech recognition interfaces
because your mouth is underwater and
there's often actually a lot of noise so
even if you use headphones it's actually
very hard to hear with all the kind of
Smashing going on so swimming just
really strongly kind of inhibit what you
can do from a design point of view
looking at this bottom axis here I have
what's for relation between our two
tusks so we've got our movement activity
which is Skinner walking on whatever
we've also got the interactive to ask so
how related are these if you think about
a Smart Watch if you've got a Smart
Watch a lot of the things that does it
kind of shows you notification so it
says you know somebody sent you an email
so if using a Smart Watch while you're
running along that's not really related
at all you know though your Smart Watch
would be right over here somewhere
whereas if you're using something like a
sat-nav in a car that's kind of directly
relates to how you're moving it kind of
responds to how you're moving where
you're going and so that's really
strongly related beyond that you have
systems that she actually kind of really
encourage your movement so if you look
at exercise systems there's these things
called exertion game
they will say now go faster now go
slower they're really just they're
making removing activity happened with
these two axes how might you design for
interaction emotion I'm gonna split this
into four quadrants here in this corner
we're designing essentially general
solutions for things so movement that's
going on isn't really related to what
the interaction is so it's you know it's
vicious things like smartwatches Google
glass that kind of thing you know it's
just you know maybe it's just showing
you notifications or some notifications
or emails but as well as that we're not
expecting people to do anything too
extreme the solutions for this might be
pretty basic stuff like make four
buttons lip a little bit bigger or use
speech interfaces if you're if you're
doing things where speech is going to be
possible so this area is roughly the
limit of what most kind of mainstream
design is for I'm going to talk about
this area next when you're talking about
quite extreme activities still like
swimming or skydiving or something like
that so something pretty intense it
takes a lot of your concentration takes
a lot of your physical ability away and
if you're designing something that's
strongly related tonight activity you
can really kind of tailor solutions for
four via for a specific activity for
example there are a couple of
interactive systems for swimming which
um which basically focus on a single
problem which is the kind of key problem
of swimming outdoors in races is
swimming in a straight line they are
specialized interfaces but they kind of
detect is someone swimming in a straight
line and say okay no you should be going
to the right a bit and show you a little
light in your goggles so you can see it
there are specific camera triggers but
you can buy for skydiving which actually
sit inside your mouth because that's the
only interaction surface you can kind of
reliably control in this corner you've
got your movement activity is something
that has a lot of inhibitions you're
saying okay I'd like to design something
for that kind of situation but I'd like
it to be you know let people do things
but aren't really related to the
situation so read their emails or
whatever slightly dramatically I call
this the danger zone the most common way
to design for this situation currently
is if you look at driving
and you know driving and Sat Navs it's
the same example the most common way to
designed for this is actually to enforce
people stopping to interact so a lot of
Sat Navs won't let you interact with
them they'll turn off their controls
while you're moving there are some other
ways which are sort of starting to come
in in cars with touch screens you can't
look at a touchscreen it's hard to hard
to and it's hard to touch controls but
various people have been looking at
using gestures on touch screens like if
you use three fingers and you slide it
down that changes for volume if you use
two fingers and you slide it down maybe
that does you air conditioning so ways
of making these touchscreen interfaces
possible to use without looking at them
this is where it's really hard and you
really need to think is it worth doing
should I just design my system so people
stopped in this corner we've got things
which are strongly related to the
movement but actually the movement
you're doing isn't really constraining
things is for design any different from
over here what you can do with design
here is it's primarily kind of aesthetic
things as a kind of interesting example
of that there's a game by Niantic labs
which is called ingress and in that you
have to kind of go to places in real
life to sort of capture they call them
portals so you capture kind of energy in
in real places and there's kind of
thousands of people around the world
playing this but at no point do you
actually really need to run fast or rive
or anything at the same time so I'm
actually there interface really it's
just kind of you know it's a classic
kind of stop to interact interface but a
really interesting thing about their
interface is they've got this it's kind
of like a scanner so it's like something
out of Star Trek you're kind of in Star
Trek you'd kind of see people we know
the scanning people like that scanning
things like that and visually it's very
much designed to fit in with that idea
that this could be some kind of Star
Trek type device this area I've called
it flexible location-based design
because your interaction is quite
strongly related to what V and what the
person is doing in terms of moving but
there aren't
many constraints on how they can
interact is this just stuff that's
involved it organically do you think do
you think we need to put a lot more
thought into this rather than just let
people just kind of build out something
fly with no knowledge of what they're
doing in user interface I think we could
build better apps if we pay if people
who were building apps paid attention to
what people are using apps actually do
with them in real life in terms of
moving your whole body twists about 50
to 60 degrees and when you look at the
magnetometer readings you get something
that looks like this graph here you can
see here it's slightly that's not you've
still a bad idea is you take that
password and you are encrypted so you